散户完短線
務必牢記七個口角
不論你現在用多少錢做股票
你都必須記住這個七個口角
而且要背著滾瓜爛手
每天睡前或是開盤前背著三次
而且要牢記嚴格執行
第一句話是什麼
連續小漲是真的
連續大漲就要離場
口頭摸摸小漲其實是為了
不被市场注意到
防止半路有资金进场去抢
打乱他们原来的布局的方式
明目张胆的大涨就是故意的
为了得到市场的关注
等到散户以及一些跟风的进来
他们就落跑了
第二句
主升加速要见顶
急跌急迈
缓涨缓卖
意思就是说
如果连续加速上涨
股价有可能短线就见到底
堆积的一些风险就越来越大
就是尽快早一点离场或者减码
因为就会产生大家赚钱猛跌
第三句话
量缩心低的底部量增回升要进场
大家都听过无量就是无价
其实逻辑都是一样的
股价跌到满足低点的位置的时候
自然就不会有人愿意割肉
要么就跌到麻痹了
成交量越来越小
自喜量之后的反弹
成交量成倍的放大
也意味着新的资金进来抢筹码
这个时候我们就要进场
第四句话
放量场宏跑光光
尾盘啊
抢筹码的人啊
我是在清仓
如果股价在高位出现一个成效量特別巨大的長紅K線要趕快離場因为第二天有可能是开高之后就快速下跌甚至只一跳空下跌开出
你就很难保住之前的获利
第五句
不冲高不卖
不跳水不买
航盘不交易
这是很重要的心理因素
冲高太快了
你要拔档
跳水跳到底
我再来买
这是短线操作最基本
最简单的道理
但是很多人都会忘记
第六句
热股不久练
换股要换心
从时拿到中
到头来是一场空
几多股票炒过之后
会有几年甚至几十年
恢复不了元气
你千万不要久抱
第七句
只做上升趋势的股票
趋势就像连续不断的山脉
就像奔向前的潮流
一旦趋势形成
有很高的基地会持续
所以做上升趋势的股票
你的胜利才能够有足够的保证
如果想知道更多的影片内容资讯
请马上加入了官方9.8
这是官方9.8
不是私人9.8
目前人数已超过5万人
加入后马上领取免费的三堂大数据讲堂的课程
如果你在回传关键字888
还可以领取当周的最新的万宝周刊杂志
还有每周一晚上八点
我还有两个小时免费线上课程
每天还有盘后的实战操作学习影片
现在马上免费订阅我的频道
我会完整跟你分享更简单的操作方法
谢谢大家